concept cars will draw big crowds today
when the New York International Auto
Show opens to the public
automakers want to show visitors
experimental designs and hints of future
models concept cars are expensive to
bill but almost never hit the open road
Kris Van Cleave got rare access to one
of the automotive design center to see
what companies invest in projects that
rarely become reality the grand reveal
of the new Lincoln Navigator is the end
of a design process that started years
ago with a sketch this is the rarely
seen Lincoln design Center in Dearborn
Michigan
it's where the cars of the future become
reality the team of designers here first
drew every angle of what would become
the Navigator after a series of tweaks
and changes it starts to take shape in
clay something car makers have done for
decades but now it's shaped with
precision by this massive computer and
then intricately finished by these
sculptors this is a clay car it's a
click oh yes so if I've been a little
bit more diligent with my play-doh as a
kid I could have made you think yeah
it's a real skill to actually be a clay
muddler and actually create this with
your hands
mori column Ford's vice president of
design says they can spend a year going
from play to concept it is to create a
buzz it is it is to anticipate people is
to give people a little bit of
excitement and to tease them when we're
going to go in the future that's what
the navigator concept did with its
sweeping goal winged or the famous
novice tour acquired job the concept of
concept cars is nearly a century old a
dozen years of automotive progress
telescoped into one effort Buicks y job
is widely credited as the first back in
1938 nearly 20 feet long with hidden
headlights and electric windows it never
made it to production but it did set the
tone for a generation of Buicks the
nation's latest experimental car by the
1950s the concept car took off with
futuristic designs never meant for the
road or even this planet they are
basically the stuff that you know
dreams are made of at low is the
editor-in-chief of Motor Trend when
things are going really really well you
get some more forward-looking kind of
vehicles in terms of the economies maybe
not so good the vehicles can be a little
bit more more conservative more staid
perhaps the most famous concept car is
the 1955 Lincoln Futura four years later
it drove Debbie Reynolds in it started
with a kiss on just dick dreaming about
pretty cars and pretty dresses
but you know the Futura not because it
became a best-seller
Batmobiles an airport but because it
became the Batmobile while some concept
cars like the Batmobile become expensive
collectors items others end up here in a
warehouse outside Detroit their
innovations promises of things to come
and the out there designs lost to
history what is a concept car cost to
build it costs quite a lot but we use to
get an investment back in terms of the
publicity get we get from it and the
message it sends their customers are we
talking hundreds of thousands of dollars
return today thousands of dollars the
concert process is really an
exaggeration of ideas david Woodhouse
runs the Lincoln design team he calls
what they do futuring the inside looks a
lot like the concept did yeah it's
remarkably similar we wanted the
customer to be transcended from their
everyday life and busyness to something
when you got into here it felt like a
century a sanctuary in concept that took
Woodhouse and his team four years to
make a reality for CBS this morning
Kris Van Cleave Dearborn Michigan loved
those cars and the thing is they also
influenced design share ethically you
know in lieu and if they don't get built
themselves and then the concept the
Batmobile was a good one
I love the thing I remain you really
can't look it back at some of these
designs and see the influence today
yes sure aesthetically absolute